nobody knows anything so do you know the
minute that someone tells you this is
exactly what's gonna happen in November
immediately discount what they're saying
this is up in the air and I I think this
is the the point about politics no one
wants to admit but it's the point that
the actually should give us the most
hope which is that nothing is inevitable
okay with the left wants you to believe
is that it's absolutely inevitable the
Democrat Joe Biden is gonna win in 2016
it was inevitable Hillary was gonna win
98% chance 99% chance and it's not it's
up in the air it's politics they have a
ton of institutional power but they
don't have all of the power we the
people still have a lot of power we can
send them a message every so often we
can do it not just here that happened in
the brexit vote it's happened all around
the West there is some popular uprising
there is some popular power and there is
a poll out from Monmouth University
Polling Institute which is an
independent polling Institute that shows
very good news for Trump on this front
it shows that the people have more power
and they're playing their cards a little
closer to their chests than they then
they might be letting on the poll is a
little bit complicated to read the
conclusions of the Poehler a little bit
complicated to get but what it basically
says is that people don't want to be
honest with pollsters people don't want
to tell everyone that they're voting for
Trump and it's not just the the same
story we heard in 2016 that phenomenon
has actually increased it's been
exacerbated people are more likely to
keep quiet about their support for Trump
most registered voters 54% say they were
surprised in 2016 when Trump ended up
winning
Pennsylvania's electoral votes they
currently are about divided on where on
where Pennsylvania's gonna go this time
46 or 45 percent one reason is that 57%
believe there are a number of so-called
secret voters in their communities who
support Trump but won't tell anyone
about it and less than half that number
27% believe that there are secret voters
for Biden so realize you eat on a poll
you can't ask people are you a secret
voter for Trump
because if by definition if you tell the
pollster that you're a secret order for
Trump then you're no longer a secret
voter for Trump
so the way the question is phrased is
about other people do you believe that
there are secret voters for Trump and so
our conclusions here are not totally
firmly consider the black lives matter
phenomenon which is the when someone
uploads a black square to social media
or someone uses the hashtag black lives
matter what they're saying is that I
believe black lives matter but a lot of
people do not however everybody has used
this phrase and everybody has said that
black lives matter so that would be an
example of people imagining that there
are all these sort of phantoms out there
but but realizing that they actually
there are not right I mean you know we
have to see there or not there's not a
scourge of Klansmen running around the
country so the question with this poll
is are the people who are saying they
believe there are a lot of secret Trump
voters out there is it just a delusion
or or they're really do they have good
reason to think there are the secret
voters I think it's the latter I think
this is good news for the Trump campaign
because the fact is everybody knows a
trump voter and if frankly everybody
knows a secret Trump voter who doesn't
want to lose his job who doesn't want to
lose his career and his livelihood this
this issue of punishment for support of
Trump has increased over the last
several years and certainly during these
race riots and the fact of the matter is
that you know Trump did win about half
the country voted for him in 2016 so
there are a lot of these people does not
mean Republicans should get complacent
more good polling news
Rasmussen shows Trump has ticked up
seven points nationally narrowed Biden's
lead to three points in recent days so
Joe Biden right now is at 47% and among
us likely voters Trump is at 44 percent
5% prefer another candidate and 4% or
undecided it's anybody's game it's
anybody's race don't let anybody tell
you otherwise
don't let anybody intimidate you into
giving up and staying home and being
locked up staying home whether because
you're afraid to go outside and breathe
the fresh air or staying home more
specifically on politics because you
don't feel that your vote will matter in
the election that is what the left is
banking on I hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the Michael Nolt show be
or to check out the full episode linked
in the description or download the
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you
[Music]